well you know there are two ways of
dancing you can be an artist or you
could dance like I do a little nerve and
a pair of hot sucks but the gracious
young couple you're about to meet our
artists ladies and gentlemen Marge and
Gower champion
give me back the good book all right
these the nominations for art direction
and set decoration of a black and white
production Julius Caesar
metro-goldwyn-mayer Cedric Gibbons and
Edward Carfagna set decoration by Edwin
B Willis and Hugh hunt Martin Luther
Louie de Rougemont associates Fritz
Moorish shot and Paul Markowitz the
president's lady 20th Century Fox
Lyle wheeler and Leland fuller set
decoration paul s fox
roman holiday' paramount al pereira and
Walter Tyler Titanic 20th Century Fox
Lyle wheeler and Maurice transferred set
decorations do it wreath the winner is
Julius Caesar art decoration
Sedgwick given and Edward Carfagna set
decoration Edwin B Willis and johann
thank you for the effort Edwin B Willis
and you hunt
and now those nominated for achievement
in art direction and set decoration in
color knights of the round table
metro-goldwyn-mayer alfred younger and
hans peter set decoration john jarvis
lily metro-goldwyn-mayer cedric Givens
and Paul Gross set decoration Edwin B
Willis and Arthur crams the road 20th
Century Fox
Lyle wheeler and George W Davis set
decoration Walter M Scott and Paul s Fox
the story of three loves
metro-goldwyn-mayer Cedric Givens
Preston Ames Edwin Carfagna and Gabriel
Scognamiglio set decoration Edwin B
Willis Keo Gleason Arthur crams and Jack
Dean more young best metro-goldwyn-mayer
Cedric Gibbons and uremic Leary set
decoration Edwin B Willis and Jack the
more you read it yeah the robe art
direction by Lyle wheeler and George
Governator
and the set decoration visor was by
Walter M Scott and Paul s Pass
by my guy
stimulating isn't it